Though they may not celebrate Christmas
in the traditional sense, our Muslim
friends have decided to give us an
amazing Christmas gift. The gift of
showing their true colors. What do they
normally say? We believe in Jesus more
than you Christians. We believe in Mary
more than you Christians. But sometimes
people only show you what they really
think when they're under pressure. And
right now the da guys are under more
pressure than Muhammad on the night of
alz.
People show you what they really are
when they go through the fire and their
plastic masks melt.
This has been the worst year in the
history of Da. Daagandists have suffered
humiliating defeat after humiliating
defeat all year long. Now they're
getting so desperate that they're
lashing out against Mary and Jesus. Take
Daniel Hiku, the world's leading
defender of both child marriage and
first cousin marriage. According to
Daniel, since Christians believe that
Jesus is God, the second person of the
Trinity, we believe that the incarnation
was incest.
If you insist that they're the same, the
same entity, the same triune God, then
it's incest. I'm sorry. There's no way
around it. Uh they they both will Jesus
will to impregnate his mother.
>> I'll just draw everyone's attention to
the meaning of the word incest.
Incest is sexual intercourse between
persons so closely related that they are
forbidden by law to marry. Does any
Christian believe that the incarnation
had anything to do with sexual
intercourse?
No. So why does Daniel call it incest?
Because Muslims have the story of the
miraculous conception in the Quran and
they believe it involved sex. So Daniel
is applying the perverted nonsense he
believes to what Christians believe. But
we'll take a closer look at the Muslim
view later. Daniel also calls the
incarnation rape. And it's rape. Okay,
it's rape because where is the consent?
>> Where's the consent? I guess we'll have
to read what the Bible says in a moment
since Daniel obviously hasn't read it.
>> Did God go to Mary in this in the Bible?
Does it describe God going to Mary and
say, you know, I want to have myself. I
want to impregnate you with myself and
I'm going to go into your womb and then
come out of your private parts. Uh, is
that acceptable to you? Did and did Mary
say yes to that? No. There's no
affirmative consent.
>> Blind leading the blind. Daniel hasn't
read the gospel and neither have his
followers.
>> So that's the rape component and that's
the incest component. That is your god.
Your god is a rapist. An incestuous
rapist. THAT IS WHO YOU'RE WORSHIPING.
Explain that. I haven't seen any
Christian explain that.
It's Christmas, Daniel. So, I'll go
ahead and explain it for you. But before
we start reading, Daniel also claims
that Mary was 12 when she became
pregnant. And he cites a second century
apocryphal source called the
protoeangelium of James to prove it.
This proto gospel is saying that she was
12 when she got impregnated. Okay? That
that is underage incest rape. Okay, she
even if she did get give affirmative
consent, it's not acceptable because
she's 12. She doesn't have a developed
mind to be able to give informed
consent. So even if Mary had consented,
her consent would be meaningless because
she was only 12 years old and 12y olds
can't consent to sex. Even though this
has nothing to do with sex in the Bible,
it only has something to do with sex in
the Quran. Shockingly, Daniel apparently
hasn't read the protoeangelium of James
either because the protoe evangelium of
James says that Mary became pregnant
when she was 16. It says, "And she was
16 years old when these mysteries
happened." This is when she was
pregnant. 16.
Again, Muslims claim to respect Jesus
and Mary. Does it seem respectful to
constantly lie about them? Isn't it
weird how Daniel can't manage to get
anything right when he attacks Jesus and
Mary? He gets basic definitions of
simple words wrong. He doesn't know
what's actually in any text he quotes.
He consistently misrepresents what
Christians believe.
Is that how you respect Jesus and Mary
in Islam?
The most hilarious part in all of this
is that even though Daniel thinks he's
attacking Christianity with these
claims, he's actually attacking Islam,
as we're about to see. So, let's read
the Christmas story in the Bible. Then,
we'll read the Christmas story in the
Quran, and we'll see why Daniel has some
explaining to do. Luke 1. In the sixth
month, the angel Gabriel was sent from
God to a city of Galilee named Nazareth,
to a virgin betrothed to a man whose
name was Joseph of the house of David.
And the virgin's name was Mary. And he
came to her and said, "Greetings, O
favored one. The Lord is with you." But
she was greatly troubled at the saying
and tried to discern what sort of
greeting this might be. And the angel
said to her, "Do not be afraid, Mary,
for you have found favor with God. And
behold, you will conceive in your womb
and bear a son, and you shall call his
name Jesus. He will be great and will be
called the Son of the Most High. And the
Lord God will give to him the throne of
his father David, and he will reign over
the house of Jacob forever, and of his
kingdom there will be no end." And Mary
said to the angel, "How will this be
since I am a virgin?" And the angel
answered her, "The Holy Spirit will come
upon you, and the power of the Most High
will overshadow you. Therefore, the
child to be born will be called holy,
the son of God. And behold, your
relative Elizabeth in her old age has
also conceived a son, and this is the
sixth month with her who was called
barren. For nothing will be impossible
with God." And Mary said, "Behold, I am
the servant of the Lord. Let it be to me
according to your word." And the angel
departed from her. How did Mary respond
to the news? Let it be to me according
to your word. Sounds like she consented
in the Bible. A little later in chapter
2, we read, "In those days, a decree
went out from Caesar Augustus that all
the world should be registered. This was
the first registration when Quirinius
was governor of Syria. And all went to
be registered each to his own town. And
Joseph also went up from Galilee from
the town of Nazareth to Judea to the
city of David which is called Bethlehem
because he was of the house and lineage
of David to be registered with Mary his
betrothed who was with child. And while
they were there, the time came for her
to give birth. And she gave birth to her
firstborn son and wrapped him in
swaddling cloths and laid him in a
manger because there was no place for
them in the inn. And in the same region
there were shepherds out in the field
keeping watch over their flock by night.
And an angel of the Lord appeared to
them, and the glory of the Lord shone
around them, and they were filled with
great fear. And the angel said to them,
"Fear not, for behold, I bring you good
news of great joy that will be for all
the people. For unto you is born this
day in the city of David, a Savior, who
is Christ the Lord. And this will be a
sign for you. You will find a baby
wrapped in swaddling cloths and lying in
a manger." And suddenly there was with
the angel a multitude of the heavenly
host praising God and saying, "Glory to
God in the highest and on earth peace
among those with whom he is pleased."
When the angels went away from them into
heaven, the shepherds said to one
another, "Let us go over to Bethlehem
and see this thing that has happened,
which the Lord has made known to us."
And they went with haste and found Mary
and Joseph and the baby lying in a
manger. And when they saw it, they made
known the saying that had been told them
concerning this child. And all who heard
it wondered at what the shepherds told
them. But Mary treasured up all these
things, pondering them in her heart. And
the shepherds returned glorifying and
praising God for all they had heard and
seen as it had been told them. And at
the end of eight days when he was
circumcised, he was called Jesus, the
name given by the angel before he was
conceived in the womb.
Anything about sex in this story? No.
Anything about rape? No. Anything about
incest? No. So why did Daniel say that
this is about incest and rape? So that's
the rape component and that's the incest
component. That is your god. Your god is
a rapist. An incestuous rapist. He said
it because of what his religion teaches.
And we're going to take a close look at
the Christmas story in the Quran. But
first, speaking of Christmas, it's only
a few days away. If there's someone you
still need to get a present for, I would
suggest doing this the easy way and not
the running around the mall scrambling
to find something on Christmas Eve way.
The easy way is Artza. Artza already did
the work for you. They put together
their brand new Christmas box called
Nativity Night, and it's their most
incredible box yet. Inside there's an
awesome handpainted ceramic plate
depicting the night of the nativity,
delicious foods and spices, a beautiful
handcarved olivewood nativity ornament
from Bethlehem, and other handcrafted
treasures that bring the story of
Christmas to life. They always end up
selling out of their Christmas boxes, so
I contacted them and asked if they're
still available and if there's still
time to get them by Christmas. They said
yes, they've still got some. And if you
order in the next few days, you should
still be able to get your box by
Christmas. Each item in your Artsa box
is handmade by local artisans and small
family businesses in places like
Nazareth and Jerusalem and Bethlehem. So
when you sign up with Artsa, you're
blessing and supporting these artisans
and families while bringing the land of
the Bible right into your home or
someone else's home. So, help a friend
or loved one experience Christmas this
year with a box of gifts straight from
the land where Jesus walked. Click the
link in the description box and get one
today. Now, for the Christmas story in
the Quran, we'll read Surah 19 16 to 26.
And remember Mary in the book when she
withdrew from her family to an eastern
place and she veiled herself from them.
Then we sent unto her our spirit and it
assumed for her the likeness of a
perfect man. So the spirit of Allah
appears to Mary in the form of a perfect
man. Most Muslims believe that the
spirit of Allah is their version of the
angel Gabriel Gabriel, but we'll come
back to that after we read the passage.
She said, "I seek refuge from thee in
the compassionate, if you are reverent."
She thought he was going to sexually
assault her. He said, "I am but a
messenger of thy Lord to bestow upon
thee a pure boy." She said, "How shall I
have a boy when no man has touched me,
nor have I been unchased?" He said,
"Thus shall it be. Thy Lord says, "It is
easy for me, and it is thus that we
might make him a sign unto mankind, and
a mercy from us, and it is a matter
decreed."
Notice that Mary asks, "How shall I have
a boy when no man has touched me?" And
Allah's reply is, "It's easy for me."
That's interesting since according to
surah 6 verse 101 Allah can't have a
child without a consort, a wife or
companion. So it's impossible for Allah
to have a child without a wife. But it's
easy for him to cause Mary to have a
child with no husband. So she conceived
him and withdrew with him to a place far
off. And the pangs of childbirth drove
her to the trunk of a date palm. She
said, "Would that I had died before this
and were a thing forgotten, utterly
forgotten." So he, baby Jesus, called
out to her from below her, "Grieve not.
Thy Lord has placed a rivlet, a small
stream, beneath thee, and shake toward
thyself the trunk of the date palm.
Fresh ripe dates shall fall upon thee.
So eat and drink and cool thine eye. And
if thou seeest any human being, say,
verily, I have vowed a fast unto the
compassionate, so I shall not speak this
day to any man. So Mary gives birth to
Jesus in a far-off place under a date
palm. And the newborn Jesus announces
that God made a stream beneath her and
that she can eat some dates. Notice that
the Quran removes Joseph from the story.
No mention of Joseph.
Why does the Quran remove Joseph when
Joseph is part of the stories that the
Quran is copying?
I suspect it has something to do with
Muhammad's father dying before he was
born. But we'll cover that in a
different video when we discuss the
psychology of Muhammad. Let's return to
this part. Then we sent unto her our
spirit and it assumed for her the
likeness of a perfect man. Again, most
Muslims believe that the spirit here who
approached Mary in the form of a perfect
man is Gabriel.
But this is a bit confusing because of
what Allah says in Surah 66.
Surah 66 is about a dispute Muhammad was
having with his wives. He got caught
having sex with his slave girl,
ironically named Mary, in the bed of his
wife, Hapsa. His wives complained about
him using their beds to have sex with
his slave girl. He told them they were
bad wives. And in verses 11 and 12, he
gives them the example of two good
women. And God sets forth as an example
for those who believe the wife of
Pharaoh, when she said, "My Lord, build
for me a house near unto thee in the
garden. Deliver me from Pharaoh and his
deeds, and deliver me from the
wrongdoing people." And Mary, the
daughter of Imran, who preserved her
chastity. Then we breathed therein of
our spirit, and she confirmed the words
of her Lord and his books, and she was
among the devoutly obedient.
We'll ignore the daughter of Imran
problem. Imran was the father of Miriam,
the sister of Aaron and Moses. Muhammad
thought that Miriam, the sister of Aaron
and Moses, and Mary, the mother of
Jesus, were the same person, even though
they lived more than a thousand years
apart. But we're focusing on this part.
Mary preserved her chastity.
Then Allah breathed therein of his
spirit.
Breathe into what? Her chastity.
How do you breathe into someone's
chastity?
Turns out lots of translators and
commentators try to cover up what this
verse actually says. In Arabic, it says
she guarded her farge, her vagina.
Here's a more accurate translation. and
Mary, daughter of Imran, who guarded her
private parts, and we breathed therein
of our spirit, and she verified the
words of her Lord and his books, and was
of the devout. Allah breathed his spirit
into Mary's private parts. Since the
Arabic says vagina, private parts is an
acceptable translation. But some
translators and commentators are so
embarrassed by this verse, saying that
Allah breathed into Mary's vagina that
they try to say Allah breathed into an
opening in her garment or they say she
guarded her chastity as if Allah can
breathe into someone's chastity. But
this is still strange because Allah says
we breathed therein.
As we already saw in surah 19, it's
Allah's spirit who appears to Mary in
the form of a man to impregnate her.
Then we sent unto her our spirit and it
assumed for her the likeness of a
perfect man. Again, Muslims believe that
the spirit, the roof, is Gabriel. So
they believe that it's Gabriel who shows
up to impregnate Mary as we see in the
commentary of Iben Cathe. And we
breathed into it her private part
through our roof, meaning through the
angel Gabriel. Allah sent the angel
Gabriel to Mariam. And he came to her in
the shape of a man in every respect.
Allah commanded him to blow into a gap
of her garment. He's trying to water
this down. And that breath went into her
womb through her private part. This is
how Issa, their version of Jesus, was
conceived.
This idea about Gabriel blowing into
Mary to impregnate her caused some
problems for Muslim theologians because
they reasoned, well, if Jabriel is
impregnating Mary by breathing his own
spirit into Mary, then Jesus would be
half angel. They didn't want a half
angel Jesus. They wanted a purely human
Jesus. So, how would they get a purely
human Jesus from Gabriel blowing into
Mary's vagina?
Well, they found the solution.
Islam teaches what's called the two
semens theory. The two semens theory was
the theory that men have semen and women
have semen. And when the two semens mix
during sex, you get a baby. Muhammad
said that a man's semen is thick and
white, while a woman's semen is thin and
yellow. According to Islam's two semens
theory, a man's semen comes from his
backbone. Since Allah wanted Jesus to be
born of a virgin, he created Mary with
both semens. She had the male semen in
her backbone and the female semen in her
womb. In order to impregnate her,
Gabriel had to blow into her vagina to
get her sexually aroused so that her
backbone would ejaculate the male semen
just like a man. But don't take my word
for it. Here's the commentary of Corte.
Allah gave Miam both fluids, some in her
womb and some in her spine. Jabriel
breathed into her to stimulate her
desire. Because as long as a woman does
not have her desire ignited, she does
not become pregnant. When that happened,
by Gabriel's breath, the fluid in her
spine descended into her womb and the
two fluids mixed and the fetus was
attached. That is why Allah then says
when he decides on something, meaning
when he wants to create something. So,
Gabriel shows up in the form of a man.
Mary thinks he's there to rape her. So,
she seeks refuge with Allah. And Allah
has Gabriel blow into her vagina to get
her aroused so that the two semens
inside her would come together forming
Jesus. But remember, Allah says, "And
Mary, daughter of Imran, who guarded her
private parts, and we breathed therein
of our spirit." Allah says he was
blowing into her vagina, too. Muslims
like Daniel think that since they
believe this sick nonsense, we also
believe it. And so they say, "We believe
that Jesus raped Mary." Muslims, not
what we believe, but it is what your
religion teaches. Since you believe that
Mary was 12 years old, and since you've
agreed that a 12-year-old is too young
to consent, and since Islam teaches that
this encounter was sexual, Allah and
Jabriel blew into Mary's vagina to get
her sexually aroused, we have no choice
but to conclude that Allah and Gabriel
gang raped the 12-year-old Virgin Mary,
according to the Quran.
You're the ones who wanted to call this
rape. I'm just going along with your
choice of words.
But what about the incest Daniel was
talking about? Christians don't believe
that the incarnation had anything to do
with sex. Muslims do believe it had
something to do with sex. But at least
the Muslim view wouldn't involve incest.
Right? Wrong. Because even though the
main view in Islam is that Mary was
impregnated by Allah and Gabriel blowing
into her vagina, there's another
interpretation that goes all the way
back to Muhammad's companions. Here's a
brief summary of the alternative view in
the study Quran. After describing the
majority position, they note,
"Alternately, the companion and early
Quran reciter and commentator Ubai Iban
Kab considered the spirit and the
perfect man references to the spirit of
Jesus who is described in 471 as a
spirit from God." According to surah 4
verse 171, verily the Messiah Jesus son
of Mary was only a messenger of God and
his word which he committed to Mary and
a spirit from him.
Some of Muhammad's companions put this
together. Jesus is a spirit from Allah.
Allah breathed his spirit i.e. Jesus
who's called a spirit from Allah into
Mary. So the spirit who appeared to Mary
in the form of a man was the
pre-incarnate Jesus. But this would mean
that Mary was impregnated by Jesus whom
she later gave birth to. What would this
be according to Daniel Hakikachu? Then
it's incest. I'm sorry. There's no way
around it. Uh they they both will Jesus
will to impregnate his mother.
>> So none of what Daniel says applies to
Christians, but all of it applies to
Muslims.
Take Daniel's rebuke of your religion,
Muslims. That is your God.
>> Muslims, your God is a rapist. Muslims,
an incestuous rapist. Muslims, it's
rape. Muslims,
>> uh, is that acceptable to you? Muslims,
>> there's no way around it.
>> Muslims, explain that.
>> Muslims,
thank you, Daniel, for the amazing
Christmas gift of exposing your religion
for all the world to see. And as I
mentioned earlier, for showing that even
though you claim to respect Jesus and
Mary, you most certainly do not. Not
even a little.
Think about this, everyone.
If all the epic da fails of 2025 are
causing the daagandists to panic and
melt down like this, forcing them to
call their own religion a religion of
rape and incest,
what do you think's going to happen in
when we really turn up the pressure?
on [music] me. You proud on that. You
proud on that. You proud on that. You
just back fine on me. This is a power of
a religion. There's a reason to it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.